but this is a thing you know we've had
prequels not sequels this is an I
haven't this is a side quote aside crow
yeah it's an extension their Will Smith
Tommy Lee Jones what they set up many
years ago brilliant and and that they
still exist in this universe as far as
this films concerned and this was an
extension that's a London branch and
wanted to give it a more of a global
feel you know the other films were shot
in in New York and had the urban
landscape there and we shot London Paris
Morocco Italy and bit New York's a
different sort of aesthetic but all the
same fun action and adventure of the
originals and then you and the new
agents test on some this film reunites
you she was Valkyrie yeah in the
Avengers and did you know when you were
doing Avengers that you were then going
on together to do this now we didn't we
had a great time originally thought
nirach we worked together and it was
fantastic and then Avengers and infinity
war endgame and this opportunity came up
and we thought fantastic we can
capitalize on the relationship
it's funny you spend like 50 percent of
a film often kind of getting to know one
another if you've never worked together
so we kind of hit the ground running
with this one so you maybe Thor know
more we don't know but if you talk about
your three kids there's a there is a
Thor in waiting in your kitchen because
this is this is one of your your twins I
think yeah yep so your your wife sent
you this video
so what's he trying to do well he's that
we've hidden in like little linen
lollies or chocolate you know which is
bribery with kids which you you know you
want to get through raising children up
high
and we thought he'll never get to them
and check this how old is he by the way
he was about three of the time he's in
the nut case
leave a three-year-old alone in your
kitchen yeah look at his hair - Wow look
at him go I'm like that's a slippery
fridge yeah
[Applause]
twin boys and the other one is highly
intelligent smart you know manipulative
in a good way
runs like he has a pair of flippers on
you know okay like it's this verdict
abilities it wasn't gifted that way that
ones is all physicality and it's an
athlete gatherer that could rule the
world
[Music]